mind your decisions I'm fresh toe Walker
consider a hemisphere whose radius is
equal to 10 construct a cube whose
bottom face has the same center as the
hemisphere increase the size of the cube
until the four corners of its top face
are touching the hemisphere now
construct a line segment from the center
of its top face to a corner of its
bottom face what is the length of this
green line this is adapted from a design
exam in India pause the video if you'd
like to give it a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on just
the cube the green line goes from the
center of its top face to a corner of
its bottom face by symmetry this will be
the same distance as going from a corner
of its top face to the center of its
bottom face we'll draw this line in blue
now let's go back to the original
diagram and focus on just the hemisphere
this blue line is exactly a radius of
the hemisphere and its radius is equal
to 10 meters therefore the length of
this line and the Green Line is 10
meters and it's that simple if you think
inside the box thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]